claude bonsoir suis ravi de t'avoir
parce qu'en général dans les émissions
de télé on a toujours des stars quand du
film à vendre et toi tu es là et a pas
de film avant c est parce que les bains
sont un sujet d'étude les bains sont
dans mes habitudes et cuits en peluche
tout c'est plus intéressant de moi aussi
de famille émission n'a rien à vendre
parce que quand on a quelque chose à
vendre obligatoirement se croit obligé
de vendre ce que l'on a
avant tandis que la bomba j'ai alors
c'est une coloration comme ça on va
prévendre n'a pu tourner court en ce
moment en ce moment je tourne l'argent
qui pourrait mettre au monde zola de la
cia ou mac avec les croupions et
miou-miou qui ne croient pas qu'ils sont
programmés avant même en un an et puis
puis avant j'ai fait dans des récents
tirs elle va sortir en janvier j'ai pas
grand chose à vendre
sauf qu'en cinéma pense que c'est vrai
je mentionne aujourd'hui je suis amusé à
faire une année une année de cap
et lorsqu'on lui ou sur ce projet de
blizzard d'après la pièce de scheepers n
en a pas je t'avais interviewé steve un
scoop à la une et tu me disais je ferai
pas le dakar cette année parce que je
polanski va mettre en scène bizarre de
schaeffers lens est devenu quoi cette
histoire ça a été je vais simplement
retardé à la place de la pièce de
schaeffer bien scène par oman j'ai joué
dans des molières
scène par planche c'est pas mal non plus
ce qui est pas mal non plus tu vas le
faire les pillards oui je pense à le
faire on va le faire après je suis pas
dans 89 cas des projets comme ça je
tends 89 rire vous des projets pas des
projets pour des projets des envies et 6
les envies voilà et cj miles and je
parle des projets rossini que profonde
ce faire le dakar cette année non
vraiment pourquoi cette année de venir
en janvier
non non non parce que en janvier je
reprends je reprends dambach au tnp y
est
donc ça correspond au fait je fais deux
ans pendant deux ans je peux même pas
dire qu'à moins qu'il reprend encore
très honnêtement je ne le sais pas non
je ne dis pas je ne crois pas je dis je
dis je ne sais pas je ne sais pas parce
que moi j'aime bien marché par par
pollution
alors bon je les fais j'ai fait était
spécifique de suite c'est pas mal pas
mal on l'a on l'a gagnée trois fois par
année
une fosse 4 83 m choi des places
d'honneur progemes 2e 5e
bon je sais pas c'est c'est une jument
vrai qu'entre 10 et une passion mal
la seule et unique passion que j'ai
c'est mon métier laventure d'aventuré
bon s'ouvrait paris-dakar ensemble une
aventure
enfin le théâtre est notre métier mais
que ce soit le dakar où que ce soit
l'asie tu as l'air de bien mais tu
éclaté quand même parce que dans les
périodes comme en ce moment on ne voit
pas mal dans les boîtes on ne voit pas
mal car la nuit aubin why are d'ailleurs
bien roulé à fond la caisse dans la
ville est toujours toujours et puis non
je suis pas prêt à dire la télé donc je
peux dire je veux dire une chose à la
télévision c'est que je fais une grosse
différence entre les alcoolos libre
l'important à donchery
oui c'était c'était une définition de
travers ouais et je suis pas inscrit
yach pas je vais je vais réaliser des
campagnes et ardon n'est vraiment pas
pas toujours quand je
j'aime pas l'alcool je peins comme par
contre c'est tentant l'ace et
c'est bien mais que diable et le bon
c'est vrai que j'aime bien et nous avons
où j'aime bien venir est ici et à paris
si c'est quoi ces bois de préférer à
paris john a très peu montré que cars
sont bas il semblerait qu'à ça va c'est
un bon et c'est un bon choix
c'est mon circuit est ce que tu crois
que tu as la même chance que ton père au
niveau des réalisateurs africains pu
tourner ce que tu penses qu'il a eu des
réalisateurs des scénaristes plus avec
plus d'envergure que ceux avec qui tu
tournes fois aujourd'hui en france
groupe kwik et c'est au fond du cinéma
non mais j'ai pas non plus à me plaindre
il faut voir ça pouvoir savoir continue
t il avait négocié vraiment fait
généralement pas que val thoiry la
journée car mélanie gay millions
tourner avec albert j'ai la chance de
tourner de tourner au noir une tournée
qu'il faut un bon fin de vacances peu le
compte est bon pour le moment oui oui
bon c'est ce qui compte c'est qu'on soit
moyens et qu'on 6 alexandre et suivent
en faire un vecteur bras ballants
troisième génération mangenot revient
d'abord à faire ce ne sera pas un
troisième ce sera la quatrième plus
avant parce que je tiendrais à petit
signe avec eux il n'y a que des clowns
dans ma famille mini s'en va donc ça me
manque encore beaucoup plus loin que sa
fille quand elle lui je lui ferais rien
faire la seule chose que je souhaite
qu'ils fassent quelque chose qu'ils
aiment et est ce qu'il a envie d'être
acteurs pour le moment oui pour le
moment oui mais j'ai envie j'ai envie
qu'il est qu'il est en vie d'acteur on
va avoir une vedette lassus connaît
prins alors oui la prime tu vas voir sur
le putsch et il avait deux médailles de
la v2 il avait deux guitaristes qui ont
fait un clip on va voir ses 26 elisa
regarde